مهندس الانقلاب القضائي الذي قلب اسرائيل
عاليها سافلها تمسك بمشروعه القانوني الذي
يقلص السلطه المحكمه العليا ويمنح صلاحيات
وحريه اكبر للحكومه والنواب انه وزير
العدل يعرفين البالغ من العمر 54 عاما من
ابرز المقربين لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو له باع وتاريخ في حزب الليكود منذ
سنواته الجامعيه يجيد اللغه العربيه لذلك
عمل في جهاز المخابرات الاسرائيلي سابقا
تولى عده حقائب وزاريه منها الامن الداخلي
وغيرها ليعين وزيرا للعدل منذ اواخر العام
الماضي في حكومه نتنياه المتشدده في
الرابع من يناير اعلن عزمه تعديل النظام
القضائي لتضمينه استثناء يسمح للبرلمان
بتعليق قرارات المحكمه العليا والهادفه
الى تحصين رئيس الوزراء بنيامين يعهو
يواجه تهما بالفساد وكذا السماح لمدانين
بتولي مناصب مثل اتمار بنكفير حينها قال
ليفين امام وسائل الاعلام ان هناك قضاه
ولكن يوجد ايضا برلمان وحكومه
والديمقراطيه في خطر حين يقرر اشخاص غير
منتخبين نيابه عن الناخبين خطوه فهم منها
سعي الحكومه الى تغلب سلطه النواب على
سلطه القضاه ودعم مشاريع اقصى اليمين الا
ان ليفين وتحت ضغط الشارع الملتهب
والتظاهرات اعلن اقتناعه باهميه تاجيل
التعديلات القضائيه حاليا